this is the argument I have with AI lob
um when when he came on my show he he
talked about this object omu mua which
is this Interstellar object that he
claims is either a junk debris or maybe
it's a tourist Scout or a spy drone
what's much more reflective rather right
it has it has properties that can't be
explained by the typical astronomical
pedantic ways of explaining things and I
told him when he came on my podcast I
love AI I've had him many times I said
AI you know why don't you go after this
thing and go track it down oh no no no
no he said in a couple years one of the
most ambitious and important
observatories is coming online and I'm
happy to recommend people that that work
on it to you when it comes out called
the Vera ruin observatory in Chile far
not too far from where my Simon our
Simon's Observatory is and that
Observatory he said is going to capture
thousands of these things if I'm right
and I said AI what if you're wrong you
know what if what if this is onetime
only event I said AI I'm I live in San
Diego and San Diego has the following uh
properties it's the absolute best and
easiest place to be a meteorologist on
the pl except for yesterday a freaking
hurricane um and a tornado and an
earthquake um but it's the absolute
worst place to be a sports caster
because we of all the major cities in
the United States we have never won a
World Championship in any sport okay so
it's horrible so last year then the
Padre's got into the division uh series
and I'm a huge Padre's fan um I I should
not have said well the Padre's are in
the division series um even though it's
the first time you know in since 19
since Tony Gwyn was playing and and
they've been around for 55 years um I'll
just wait till next year no no no no no
I I I made every I tried to get tickets
I scalped I couldn't get tickets because
you don't know if your calculations are
correct but if you believe in what
you're saying track this thing down and
oh by the way Avi you happen to know a
guy named Yuri Milner who's already
paying your team and funding you not
personally he's funding a team called
the break breakthrough star shot have
you heard about this no they're gonna
send uh billions of little cell phone
cameras uh to proximus and Tory
B you're not supposed to laugh sounds
insane to laugh anyway they're spending
$100 million on it um and they're going
to shoot these things there and they'll
get there in four 20 years and they'll
transmit at the speed of light it'll
take another four years to get back to
the Earth because four light years away
um instead of having him spend a 100
million on that why don't you get him to
you know get a little Cube sat and shoot
it off and go catch up to UU while it's
still in your freaking neighborhood
totally
totally possible it's not so you think
he's resisting that because it doesn't
like he doesn't want it to be disproven
because he's getting a lot of attention
off of this idea that this is this
Interstellar object is something from an
alien civilization I think that's too
venal I I don't think I don't think he's
doing it out for attention I just think
he's he's he's too in love with his
numbers he's too in love with his
calculation too in love with the idea of
it but certainly there is a tempt there
has to be a temptation to getting
recognition because I had never heard of
him until a few years ago and now I hear
about him constantly he's in all these
interviews and and this is not
disparaging no no it's just that there's
a there's an Impulse that people have to
get continue to do something that gets
them a lot of recognition oh sure I mean
this is this is the number one if he's
If he if it's possible to go take a look
at that thing how much would it cost to
go take a look at that thing it would
probably cost less than a billion
dollars say and this guy that he's
friends with is far be it for me to tell
a billionaire how to been his or her
money but I'm just saying I don't think
you're going to talk Elon Musk into go
on looking at it right well elon's
another
cat